[موسيقى]
دخول اسلحه الشيطان المرعبه الى الخدمه
فمتى تبدا موسكو باستخدامها
ونحتاج للامداد بشكل عاجل ووزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تواجه اوكرانيا بالحقيقه المره
وفرنسا تغير موقفها من اوكرانيا والهدف
دائما هو روسيا فما الذي يجري اوروبا دخان
المليارات لاجل اوكرانيا وبريطانيا تضع
يدها في النار ومن جديد الطائره
الاوكرانيه تتسكع فوق الكرملين
في الخزائن الاوروبيه وحيله لجات لها
الدبابات الاوكرانيه تقلب طاوله الهجوم
المضاد بايدن يضر الرماد في اعين الرئيس
الصيني وبكين تتولى الرد و واشنطن تبيع
صواريخها للسعوديه وقطر واسرائيل تصب جام
غضبها على الاراضي الفلسطينيه فان
المتشدقون
الانسان
الشيطان الروسي يدخل الحرب ليست المره
الاولى ولن تكون الاخيره خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه ولا ندري كم مره سيعلن الغربون
فهد اسلحتهم ليعلنها الامين العام لحلف
[موسيقى]
النيتوداد بشكل عاجل هناك شمرت لندن عن
ساعديها لتستضيف مؤتمرا لدعم اوكرانيا
ويعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
الاقتصاد الاوكراني بنحو ثلاثه مليارات
دولار على مدى الاعوام الثلاثه المقبله
فهل نفهم من هذا ان الحرب الاوكرانيه
ستستمر لثلاثه اعوام اخرى قادمه بينما
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاده
ستقدم مساعده اقتصاديه جديده لاوكرانيا
قدرها مليار وثلاثمائه مليون دولار فياال
هذه المجز الماليه ماذا لو سقطت احدى هذه
المليارات سهوا ليتم تزويج المعصرين عن
الزواج
سيدعون لكم بالنصر وعندها ستنتصرون واظن
ان هذه اسرع طريقه للنصر
لنكمل المقاله وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
ضد تجنيد الصراع في اوكرانيا وهذا يعني ان
الحلف يريد القتال ونحن نعلم ذلك وجاهزون
للقتال وفق خوله وهناك ان امريكا لا تبالي
بالخسائر الاوكرانيه حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ان واشنطن ادركت منذ
البدايه ان الخسائر الاوكرانيه خلال
الهجوم المضاد ستكون كبيره لان ذلك جزء لا
يتجزا من الصراع فياال بروده اعصابهم وعلى
العكس تماما ادركت قبرص الحقيقه وعلى لسان
رئيس انيكوس كريستودو الذي قال
[موسيقى]
والا فانها ستبقى غير محميه لكن فرنسا على
الطرف الاخر قد غيرت موقفها بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف النيتو وبعد رفضها
لانضمام كييف للحلف قد صارت تعتبر هذا
الخيار ضمانا للامن في حد ذاته وذلك بحسب
صحيفه حيث تستهدف المبادره الفرنسيه زياده
الضغط على روسيا في وقت يواجه فيه الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد صعوبات متعدده وتلك
الصعوبات اكدها وزير الدفاع الروسي الذي
قال انه منذ الرابع من يونيو كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه
على مواقع روسيه في
وتم صدها جميعا لتفجرها مجله بيلد
الالماني بقولها بان روسيا بدات بشني هجوم
مفاجئ على محاور خركوفا لوغاسك مؤكده ان
قله من الناس توقعت حدوث هذا الامر لتزيد
روسيه الطين دله باعلانيه ان قواتها صدت
هجمات عديده للجيش الاوكراني معظمها على
ثلاثه محاور اساسيه مشيره الى مقتل نحو
835 جنديا اوكرانيا خلال 24 ساعه مهلا
مهلا مهلا فنحن غير مسؤولين عن صحه هذه
الاعداد وكما تشاهدون الان حيث تم نشر هذا
الخبر في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
ارتي اما طواقم وافراد الدبابات
الاوكرانيه فلجاوا الى الحيله لتجنب
القتال في الهجوم المضاد حيث يتظاهرون
بوجود عطل للتهرب من القتال وذلك وفق مجله
اشبجل الالمانيه وهناك اعترف
الرئيسكي اخيرا بان الهجوم المضاده للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه يتحرك ابطا مما كنا
نود وفق قوله لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن
بانه تم اسقاطه ثلاث طائرات طيار فوق
موسكو بواسطه وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه
خلونا ندخل في التئل قال رئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان الثالوث النووي مهم
لضمان امن روسيا واستقرار التوازن العالمي
واشار الى ان صاروخ سرمت سيدخل الخدمه
قريبا بالتزامن مع اعاده تجهيز القوه
العسكريه بانظمه صاروخيه حديثه وبرؤوس
حربيه تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت
عن دخول صواريخ صرمات الثقيله والعبره
للقارات الخدمه في القوات المسلحه الروسيه
الصواريخ الملقبه بالشيطان قادره على حمل
عشره رؤوس نوويه او اكثر وها هي قد اصبحت
جاهزه للقتال فهل يدخلها بوتين في الحرب
الاوكرانيه ام انه يخبئها في حال المواجهه
مع الغرب والنيتو اوكرانيا لم تصمت امام
تهديدات النوويه هذه ليصرح
بان سلطات بلاده تامل في ان تقوم الدول
الغربيه بتحويل ما يصل الى 500 مليار
دولار من الاصول الروسيه المجمده في
الخارج الى كيب لكن وكاله
الاتحاد الاوروبي وصلت الى استنتاج بانها
لا تستطيع بشكل قانوني مصادره كل الاصول
الروسيه المجمده ليعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
هنا عن فرض قيود ضد 70 شخصا وثلاثين شركه
ومؤسسه والفرع الجنوبي لخط دروغبا وكذلك
منع الشاحنات مع المقطورات من روسيا وذلك
ضمن الحزمه الحاديه عشره من العقوبات ضد
روسيا
الاحداث والتطورات
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان وصف
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للرئيس الصيني
بالديكتاتور ينتهكوا بشده الكرامه
السياسيه للصين ويصل الى حد الاستفزاز
السياسي العلني
[موسيقى]
وماذا عن المهرولين للتطبيع بوتين يعطي
الضوء الاخضر للشيطان الروسي بينما يشكو
الغرب من نفاد اسلحتهم فماذا يخبئ لنا
الزمن في احشاء الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]